ever since we learned that House
Democrats would be taking over control
of the House of Representatives with the
majority after the 2018 midterm
elections we've been trying to sort of
figure out well what are their
priorities going to be what should their
priorities be what are they going to be
investigating and what sort of decisions
are they going to make about obstructive
attempts that Republicans when in
control of the house made one such
attempt is the fact that the House
Intelligence Committee when still
controlled by Republicans before early
January when Democrats were sworn in
into control of the House of
Representatives the house Intel
committee run by Republican Devin Nunez
did everything they could to avoid
sending transcripts of a number of
witness testimonies over to Robert
Muller and over to the Justice
Department for analysis and to become
possibly part of future indictments
there are more than 70 such interviews
that the House Intelligence Committee
did
these include Donald Trump jr. and Jared
Kushner and it's possible that these are
sort of the last pieces of the puzzle
that investigators would need in order
to actually process some indictments so
for example with Roger stone we know
that Robert Muller generally knew the
content of Roger stones testimony for a
while but in late December or mid to
late December but I think between the
15th and 20th of December Muller and his
team received the official Roger stone
transcripts and about four to five weeks
later Roger stone was of course arrested
and indicted so it's possible that
Robert Muller already has a pretty good
grasp and handle on what it is that
Donald Trump jr. and others said in
their testimonies and is waiting on the
official transcripts in order to make
the determination that it's time to
process indictments it's possible that
they won't what we do know is that
Donald Trump jr. had privately been
telling friends that he does expect that
he is going to be indicted by Robert
Moeller at some point so this is a
really really big
the question of will the House
Intelligence Committee now controlled by
Democrat Adam Schiff rather than by
Trump crony Devin Nunez will they make a
decision to get these transcripts over
to robert muller and so what happened
yesterday the House voted and they voted
yes the house is sending transcripts
from more than 50 witnesses to robert
muller
and to investigators additionally it's
important to remember that when this
same Intelligence Committee was
controlled by the Republican Party up
until before early January they stalled
on delivering these transcripts which
may have stalled indictments from
happening that's not happening anymore
so whose testimony is being sent over we
don't actually know we presume that
Donald from juniors testimony and Jared
Kushner is testimony are being sent over
it's important also to remember that
this goes not just to robert muller but
it also goes to the Department of
Justice and these transcripts can be
used for all ongoing investigations will
the public ever see these transcripts we
don't know Adam Schiff is the new
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and he said that he is going
to review whether they are ultimately
going to release any of these
transcripts publicly but the the most
important takeaway here is that things
have been sort of quiet recently in
terms of indictments other than
obviously that major indictment of Trump
inner circle strategist Roger stone we
could be sort of overdue for indictments
and whether it's Donald Trump jr. or
someone else it could trigger from to
lash out in ways we haven't seen thus
far
I got a few emails suggesting that Jared
Kushner is going to be next to be
indicted I highly doubt that a couple
people emailed me and said Ivanka is
next I don't even know that that's on
the table at this point but Donald Trump
jr. is the name that we keep going back
to and I can only imagine that Donald
Trump is going to be very very triggered
if his son gets indicted I'm guessing he
wouldn't be able to pull the
he was barely involved he's not an
inner-circle member he was just backing
on his own I don't know anything he was
doing it's his son after all I don't
think Trump will be able to defend
himself in that way but we'll see maybe
he'll disown Don jr. in an effort to
preserve his himself I don't know
unfortunately there are lots of people
that are still ignoring the seriousness
of these transcripts being sent over
there have been indictments already for
people for lying to Congress and if Don
Jr did it and got indicted it's possible
he would have to go to prison I mean
this is this is just not a joke at all
and the idea that there's a lot of
people laughing off these transcripts as
irrelevant maybe nothing will come of it
but I don't know that Donald Trump jr.
is willing to take that risk especially
when he said he anticipates that he may
indeed be indicted
according to reports about what he's
been telling his friends how long might
it take once the transcripts get to
Robert Muller it could be a while as one
data point I believe it was right around
the middle to the to the 20th or so of
December when the official Roger stone
transcripts were sent over to Robert
Muller and it took a little over four
weeks four to five weeks for the stone
indictment to happen so it could be 30
to 40 days even if there is an
indictment planned of Donald from jr.
before we actually see it but if there
is any takeaway from this you can tell
that we're now getting sort of into the
20/20 election because the take away
from just about every story on the David
Pakman show now is this may make no
difference at all
two trumpets and we need to vote in 2020
the 2018 midterms were not 100% what we
wanted but as a result of Democrats
taking over the house and thus the House
Intelligence Committee there are
actually some things starting to happen
later in the program I'm going to tell
you about a very big new house
investigation into foreign influence on
Donald Trump and on phos possible
finance
crimes by Donald Trump so if you look
back at the 2018 midterms and you say it
wasn't enough I wish more had happened
I'm right there with you but the results
in the house were very good and it's
leading to some tangible results
including these investigations including
these transcripts finally getting over
to robert muller which we've been
waiting for for a very very long time
make sure you're following me on
instagram by the way i posted a picture
of a cat two days ago
that's it I mean it's just a picture of
a cat I don't know what else to tell you
but people seem to like cat pictures
online and I posted one and you can see
it on my Instagram page at david dot
pakman make sure to also follow the
david pakman show on instagram polls top
comments all sorts of great stuff on the
david pakman show instagram page at
david pakman show we will take a very
very brief break it'll be over before
you know it and Molly McHugh joins me
next